a new study shows that most men can
identify a gay man by his face alone
it's the face that's buried in another
man's [__] all right Billy Bob
Thornton's very
the only the only um thing that bums me
out though is that you're not you're not
supposed to laugh at gay people when
they're funny because sometimes they
just are they're funny like I lived in
New York for a lot of my life and in my
neighborhood everybody was gay and and
it you know some guys are just a guy
walking down the street but some gay
guys are a guy in little shorts and a
half shirt and you know combat boots
spray painted green and the whistle and
he's standing on the corner going hello
it's [__] hot outside
and when I see them I laugh really loud
I just do
and be like don't laugh at him because
he's getting no I'm not I'm laughing
because he's [__] weird and silly
hilarious
how am I supposed to react hello oh
hello hello yes
seriousness yes
I got buddies that were very homophobic
man like to the point where they
couldn't even share a bed with me
Hotel king-sized bed
buddy of mine is freaking out he's like
dude I don't know if we're gonna share
this bed we should put some blankets and
pillows in the mirror to bed
create an anti-gay structure you know
protect us from the gay
it's cool you know or you could not [__]
me how about that was that
is that a good idea just brainstorming
here
pretty sure nothing Gay's gonna happen
if we just go to sleep and then you know
wake up and [__] me I think that's how
the gay show works
I'm a little nervous of yourself
to not [__] me in the night
you need a barricade to not [__] your
friend that's
concerning okay because I know if I woke
up I just look at you and be like I
don't want to [__] them
but apparently you're waking up like I
want to [__] them but I don't want to
climb
my boy is furious he's like no no this
should see you through another gate of
me bro you're the [__] gay one dude
I was like first of all
if I was gay what makes you think some
blankets and pillows
are gonna stop me from getting what I
want
if I'm gay I'm going in
I'm using a pillow so no one hears you
someone's cheeks are getting cracked
we've come a long way from it being
punishable to Total equalities it should
be of course and England the guys you
can send same as heterosexuality now
um 16 and even gay marriage
um although ironically the one place
that was really ahead of the game fell
behind a little at the last election
California they had a referendum they
put it to the vote and they voted no to
gain marriage I mean in California
there's people going that's why we moved
here I mean it's a it's a strange sort
of bigotry that you can affect someone
else's lifestyle that doesn't affect you
back it's not like they asked the bloke
once said sorry um do you mind if these
two men get married he went no fine okay
Jack them off then what I didn't know
that was
that doesn't happen doesn't it that
doesn't happen look it's also a strange
sort of bigotry because these people
that object to that were presumably the
same people that said you know gay
people were immoral and promiscuous but
now they don't want to be monogamous and
respectful in the eyes of God and it
must be so confusing to a gay guy in
California thinking that's the bit they
don't like with all the other [__] we
get up to it's the marriage bit that
we're so confused they must go to judges
and go sorry can I get the rules
straight what do you want to know I just
didn't know what we can and can't do ask
away can I marry a man no
can I [__] him up the ass and give him a
little reach round
please
can't marry him no
no bud in the middle
come on
can I pick up a stranger in the bushes
and take him home in Jesus name and
throw him out in the morning or crusty
and homeless
of course you can yeah but I couldn't
marry him no and no and don't ask again
could I line up 15 men
I'm just riffing here
can I line up 15 men and just Jack them
off
for a laugh if you want yeah yeah it'll
be difficult wouldn't it jacking off 15
minute one it'd be like plate spinning
wouldn't it no
no because you'd have you could only do
two at once really so you'd have these
two ready to blow but then they'd be
losing it and you'd go
here we go
I didn't knock her in jacking off 15
minutes ones never thought I'd say that
oh
again
um no
that's all I'm saying it was just it was
one of one of those moments this girl
was annoying me she was eating something
and I was envisioning plunging her face
right into it
all right this is basically what
happened okay she tried to say I was
homophobic I think she's full of [__]
and this is the story all right
we were in a diner right we just got
done eating okay came out I was looking
down at the ground and when I looked up
there was like these two dudes like
hardcore making out you know and it's
like I wasn't [__] ready you know
what I mean
because it was all it was I wasn't ready
it's like you know if you rent a
Brokeback Mountain or I'm walking
through the village I can get my brain
prepared
for what I might see but it's like I
wasn't [__] ready you know I just
eating these fries my god you dumb [__]
you got to go to the gym you know it's
in my own head but when I looked up
these two dudes one guy had a beer
there's ah just going at it
so the second I looked up I just went
like uh
that's all I did real quick I just and
then this girl was just glaring at me I
kind of God
was that what you're like homophobic are
you homophobic okay no no homophobic I
got no hatred you know
I got no hatred in that area she goes
what the hell I thought
it was it was just like a visual thing
it was just you know
she goes what are you talking about well
put it this way the first time I've ever
saw a porno I was like 14 years old I
had no idea what doggy style was but the
second I saw it my brain was just like
that is the [__] I want to [__] do
that at some point in my life I'm gonna
convince a woman to do that with me
right my brain was like yes my dick was
up everything was in agreement
that this was a wonderful thing and I
had no idea what it was
but in the same token if at any point
during that porno if somebody started
like kissing somebody's feet or like
sucking on their toes it was just it was
just gross to me
but that doesn't mean I hate feet and I
don't want them in my neighborhood
because I'm not into that [__]
it's the same thing with the Gaithers I
have no hatred in my heart for gay
people all right they're cool they're
funny generally speaking they're neat
you know
[Music]
they moved your neighborhood the
property value goes up because they make
it fabulous right
they can't reproduce so they're not
making more in the way people walking
around looking up the [__]
they're wonderful for the environment
God bless them
but how far does political correctness
go that I gotta look at some [__] that's
making my brain go like ah [__] look
away right
supposed to override that start like
cheering on the relationship like
yeah run your fingers through his chest
hands
[Applause]
dude it's ridiculous
you're gonna tell me some gay guy never
walked down the street seen two straight
straight people just going at it and
never just saw like oh God why would you
I just had to like Walk It Off
you can't help it that's just how his
brain is wired right
he's just like [__] uh and I'm like
dick right
but there's no hatred in that
I can't I don't know I just couldn't
[__] explain it to this girl
she's like yeah I think your homophobic
it's like no it was on the same level
you ever see a big guy in a sandwich
right and he gets a little mustard on
the side of his face right you [__]
look away
but that doesn't mean you want him to
choke on the sandwich and you want to
get a bunch of friends to beat the [__]
out of him for eating a sandwich right
do whatever you put your mouth on is the
most intimate thing ever right there's
no middle ground it's either like yes or
[__] that there's no middle there you
know balls right
[Applause]
you just and you just insert yourself
into the situation like when you watch a
porno there's there's a guy and a girl
but you're not looking at the guy even
though he's right there you're just
looking at the girl and you're just
thinking yeah that's what I would be
doing to her right
but if you took the girl out and there
was just some guy just sitting there
just dry humping he'd be like this [__]
is horrific right
so when I'm looking at two dudes kissing
it's like a stalemate there's no place
for me to insert myself into that
situation
that isn't horrific right
does that mean I'm [__] up you know
what I love about that joke you guys got
it after like the first example yet I
felt the need to give you 58 more
examples
look I should be able to say something
about gays look I I said something on a
podcast I did a long time ago or my my
whatever whatever they called it that
little show I would do
and I and I was playing the president
the the president and I go why is being
gay
of preference
and tying a [__] up and peeing on her a
fetish
yeah why is who I decide to [__] some
type of profound fight I just want to
have that discussion because I'm here to
say look it's not about love because I
can go man I love you man I love you too
man brotherly I love you I love a man
but it ain't gay until I'm [__] you I
love my dog I love my dog but it's not
bestiality unless I'm [__] my dog so
you start [__] so if I [__] have a
crush on you and I never tell you I'm
not gay right I'm just and in fact we
invented this thing called man crush
that says a heterosexual man who looks
at another man with some type of
reverence but he's not [__] him yeah
why can't you talk about this situation
what do you want you know what Define to
me what it is what are you asking for to
get married no no what's coming out the
closet coming out the closet so I can
let everybody know and see here's the
thing I don't give a [__] but I'm saying
look let's say I like tying [__] up
and peeing on them right I want to be
able to show everybody
by some type of flag
some type of gesture that I wanna I'm
tired of hiding that I like peeing on
[__] I'm tired I want everybody to
know because I don't want to live this
way no more I want you to know that I
like to do that and there are other
people that like to do a lot of people
like to do it and I want to get together
with those people and share our
experiences
on each other and I want to fight to get
married to a person under the guise that
I like peeing on somebody
now if I'm saying some [__] up [__]
please
talk to me make me see different because
I don't give a [__] be gay but it's the
it's forcing me to I can't say nothing I
can't say [__] you can't and and no one
will no one will have that conversation
with you you will be [__] chastised
ostracized
right I'm not homophobic right I'm not
looking here's my stance on abortion
kill your baby if you want but don't say
it's your body [__] it ain't your body
you're not special
it's because God science whatever you
believe in Just Cause You're the
apartment building for the baby doesn't
make you special you're not special
the entire create the entire baby
process is special but you were chosen
because whether by any meanie miney mo
rock paper scissors a flip of the coin
that's where the baby be it's you but am
I gonna [__] burn abortion clinic
down no right but I'm just saying I have
an opinion about it I have a [__]
opinion about it and I'm not saying kill
gaze and gays can't but I'm saying what
are you making me think you're comparing
black to gay I can't not be black what
if I don't I don't do
I'm black